I look at this category and how much
money is in this
category and um it's going to happen
it's just there's never been a business
there's never been a carcass so tempting
so bloated swimming so
[Music]
slowly all right we just asked Scott
Galloway if he was 25 years old again
what businesses would he start cuz this
guy started I think nine businesses sold
won for over $100 million and we said if
you were 25 what would you do what are
the ideas the opportunities the trends
that you would take advantage of and he
gave us two answers he said if you had
no degree no college degree no fancy
education he would do this and he said
if I had a fancy degree instead I would
do this other thing very cool to hear
kind of where his head's at the small
opportunities and the big one what he
called the the multi- trillion dollar
carcass that he can't believe nobody has
uh has disrupted yet and on top of that
we asked about his finances we talked
about when he sold his companies and
made his first few million bucks and
then tens of millions of dollars all the
way up to how he got over $100 million
how he lost it along the way and what
were the key moments that allowed him to
to reach those Heights with his with his
own finances you know I've seen probably
100 interviews with Scott Galloway and
I'd never heard him reveal these numbers
or talk about this so openly in fact at
one point he goes I'm naked here I'm
naked here guys you got to tell me
something and so uh very very good
interview with Scott Galloway enjoy
welcome to the Pod uh I've been uh I've
been listening to you for a very long
time I was a fan of yours starting I
think with L2 with the No Mercy No
Malice videos and the reason I've liked
you is I find myself you might be 15 or
20 years older than me but I find myself
looking up to you because I think we
have a lot of very similar
characteristics which are a rotile
disfunction not yet anger
depression um I have hair but you're
pretty buff you might be buffer than me
I I admire you for that thanks for that
uh like you like to post shirtless pics
I like you for that I do but you're very
hard to Peg down politically you're
you're you're you're kind of like all
over the map when it comes to that you
also you you have beautiful language I'm
a big fan of beautiful language you've
got beautiful language you're better
than I am but I look so I look up to you
for that and you started a bunch of
really amazing businesses but you're
kind of known like I've told we did this
episode where we talked about personal
finances where you talked about spending
2 to 400,000 a month and people were
like I you know Scott was so rich and I
was like no he he created a bunch of
really big companies but you're more
famous for being like Scott Galloway the
brand and I think that that's pretty
cool and so you've done a bunch of
really interesting stuff this is the
whole episode by the way it's just Sam
complimenting you it's like a reverse
roast actually so you just sit there and
you just get compliments at the end of
the hour you know you feel good that
that that's what happens here yeah so
far I just let me say I'm really
enjoying
this it's like a verbal massage this is
this works for me uh anyways go on keep
going
s well like I read these sentences and
I'm like that's a beautiful line I love
that [__] I just love how he's coming up
with that stuff um but yeah I mean I
think it's like I think it's really good
and what's crazy is you've had a better
career as a as a business person and I
was said the key to my success is is
rejection and that is I've had a lot of
the marketplace businesses Capital
providers women uh have provided a great
deal of rejection for me and my skill is
my ability to endure that and move on
and not let lose my sense of enthusiasm
you know the ability to mourn and move
on is key and the wonderful thing about
America is that we don't Embrace failure
that's [__] but we tolerate it and I
know so many really successful people
who are very successful and then they do
something on their own or they do
something and it doesn't work for them
and they get stuck they just lose their
Mojo and they can't get past it they
can't handle the bullet to the to the
chest or the Bullet to the arm becomes
an opportunistic infection that starts
damaging everything about them and I've
that's my only skill I'm OB you know I'm
really into my dogs I started an
e-commerce company I want to be the
williamsa pet supplies I put a million
bucks of my own money in I sold it for
like a million and a half so I made some
money not a lot
um I invested or I started another
e-commerce company I started a travel
site sold that for a little bit of money
um you know I've had a lot of kind of
and then I've had things where I you
know I ran into a you know drove into a
wall at 200 miles per hour I started
coming a red envelope which went public
on the NASDAQ in 2002 and because I was
young and dumb I kept investing and then
I got in a war with the board and I did
a proxy fight and I took over the board
and put more of my money in and then
2008 came came and there's a long shoran
strike and a software malfunction at the
warehouse where we sent 10,000 gifts to
the wrong addresses over the holidays
and then a Wells Fargo analyst who was
like 14 decided the credit crisis was
coming and pulled our line and my stock
went from seven bucks a share to zero in
about 11 days and when the company had
declared chapter 11 and I lost you know
I lost pretty much everything do you
remember how much money uh when you felt
that Tipping Point where you did feel
financially secure not like bulletproof
where nothing will ever will happen but
do you remember the inflection point
where you're like okay this feels
different than I've felt on on the climb
I still don't I still haven't hit that
point I'm still very anxious about money
you know I had and I like to be very
open about money because I think that
not talking about money is basically a
decorum that is promoted by the
incumbents and the wealthy such that you
don't understand how much money wealthy
people have to keep poor and middle
class people under the illusion that oh
you you should be paying 45% taxes while
I'm paying
17 and I think I think it's important to
be very I think it's helpful to be
transparent and I talk about how much
money I've lost all my investments how
much money I've gained my tax rates
Etc but the the you know I'm I'm still
I'm not obsessed with money I think
about it all the time I'm trying to get
a lot more I'm I'm giving it away I five
from five years ago I decided I was
going to give away every dollar I made
in current income um because I want to
start catching up to the non-
philanthropic Scott for the first 45
years of his life but I'm still trying
to make a [__] ton of money I still feel
financially very insecure I still worry
about a recession becoming a depression
and I'm the guy who lost it again I've
lost it all a couple times and so I
don't feel I'm at that point where I
don't have Financial anxiety I do sleep
with one eye open the big you know I
sold my first company company for 28
million bucks by the time I split it
with my
ex and my partner in taxes I ended up
with a few million dollars Red Envelope
I got a few million there but I always
seem to figure out a way to lose it but
I was able to start again because I
never had debt I've always lived below
my
means um uh but I would say the big win
was probably selling L2 and I like that
oh wow I can buy a plane like that was
not in my reach before um so that was
kind of the big one that was like all
the moons line what was the price what
did it sell for $200 or $300 million no
it sold for $1 158 million but we'd only
done one round of venture capital so the
you know the common shareholders you
know I was the largest Equity owner um
so the top you know between me and the
top six employees we probably own 70% of
it um so that was that you know that was
a lot of money for me I'd never had that
kind of money before I'd always done
well well but I'd never had that kind of
that kind of capital and then getting to
invest that in the midst of a bull
market we sold in
2017 um you know i' I've made more money
investing actually than I've made from
my small from my businesses and I'm I
got a book coming out of March about uh
Financial um trying to develop Financial
Security and you know the ability to
create a army of capital even if it's
only 50 bucks a month or 100 bucks a
month put it in a tax deferred or tax
efficient vehicle ver ify it and then
let time take over against see above you
don't know how fast time is going to go
that's where I've built real
wealth our software is the worst have
you heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better this
doesn't this doesn't make sense for
Shawn because Shawn is not worried about
money at all he's got this thing that I
like to call like good emotional health
he's very emotionally healthy his his
parents did did him well and he's talked
to me about this I sold my company two
or three years ago and I made a fair bit
not I'm I'm like I'm naked here what did
you me yeah let's go let's go Sam you
got to say he's hesitant he's hesitant
because he's worried people listen okay
go ahead uh at the end of the the
process uh I walked away with about $20
million that and how old are
you uh I was about 30 I was 31 or 32 so
you should be extraordinary you should
be unless you really screw up you should
be much wealthier than I am by my age
because to get that yeah but I still I
still feel shitty I feel the same like I
still like I felt awesome for a minute
and then I felt shitty where I was like
oh like when I see these world events
right now when I saw like whatever
happens every 6 months I'm like the
world's going to end and and I do uh
like an I'm boring Sean makes fun of me
I do 8020 index and bonds that's the I
only own exactly what you should be
doing right now I think so and I and
then I own Hub fot stock still and then
I own Airbnb stock that's basically
basically my portfolio and um Sean makes
fun of me he's like how are you feeling
insecure I'm like dude I'm broken like
I'm broken like I it doesn't matter how
much therapy I go to I'm just I'm a
broke when it comes to money I have a
scarcity mindset and I'm broken yeah I'm
the same way and when you talk about how
you're worth you know 100 million plus
and you don't feel feel secure and Sean
said he's like what a little [__] like
you know like you talk about masculinity
man up you know what I mean like it's
and I have the same thing I'm like I I
can't so I'll give you I'm weak by but
the only thing I would say is just uh I
both of you guys obviously super smart
guys and you know it's sort of
irrational that you're feeling that way
and I guess the question I would have
Scott is like uh like you know you
actually are financially secure now
right like it would take um it would
take a lot for you to get to the point
where you're not able to fund your
lifestyle or provide for your family or
whatever at this at this point um so you
know that that anxiety is is somewhat
irrational and you're a very smart guy
and you've clearly like done the
self-development work in a bunch of
other areas of your life I'm just
surprised that I like I can't tell is it
just one of these like virtue signal
things where you're like hey guys I'm
just I'm still like you I'm still I
still sweat it and I'm like oh is that
what these guys are doing they're just
trying to relate to the common man um or
are you actually just not like fixing
that irrational part of your brain and
just being like uh you know you know
working on that like getting it getting
it right um which one is it yeah so
first off the Neurosis is real it's not
a it's not a humble brag it's part of a
brag but it's not a humble BR it's the
Neurosis is real but it's
also it's also a feature as well as a
bug because I'm all over the people
managing my money I know where my money
is I think a lot about diversifying Sam
what you're doing is exactly what you
should be doing cuz you're not looking
to get you're looking to get richer but
more than anything you're looking to not
get poor and the mistake I made at your
age when I had some wins was I would
double down and I would start another
company and put all my money into one
thing like you're quite frankly you
should be selling down your Airbnb and
your HubSpot stock and just letting you
don't need the needle in a Hy stack you
just need to buy the whole Hy stack cuz
got enough capital I have a price Target
like I I I have like a number where I'm
like when we get to around this we're
going to we'll get out of those yeah but
I would do do I mean a longer
conversation but Sean tier I think about
financial insecurity a lot it is still
very possible you know there's been
periods in economic history where if
you're invested and you know you can
lose most or all of it um I've put a
little bit of pressure on myself because
and this is virtue signaling I give a
lot of money away so but yeah I don't
and also I have a really nice
lifestyle but no the insecurity is still
there I I I was always financially
insecure growing up and I just don't
know if that goes away but I I think
some of it is a good thing I have my eye
on stuff I think about it a lot and it's
like if you want to be good at money if
you want to be good at anything if you
want to be good at tennis if you want to
be good at Stam collecting you need to
think about about it a lot it doesn't
you know Roger Federer thinks about
tennis a lot a lot and if you want to be
good at money uh I think you have to
have a certain amount of financial
literacy you have to understand interest
rates you have to be thinking wait when
my mortgage rolls in 14 months is it
going to go from 2 and a qu% to 7% oh
wait it is does that mean I should be
thinking about selling it paying off my
mortgage you just if you want to be
wealthy unless you're extraordinarily
talented at something
I mean extraordinarily talented and also
can live below your means and most
extraordinarily talented people have a
tough time living below their means it's
not how much you make it's how much you
know you spend in your ability to create
a Delta so you always save below live
below your means yeah the the insecurity
is real it really I still am very
fearful of being broke I don't I don't
want to go back there and not only that
I'm getting to an agro I I don't have
that much time to make it back so no the
insecurity the insecurity is real what
helps is is that you have cash flow now
like a lot of startup people you're poor
you're poor you're poor and then you're
poor for seven years then you maybe
hopefully have an exit then you get a
windfall and then it feels good for a
little while and then you're like but
there's there's no more income um what
changed for me because this podcast and
Sean this podcast has done well is and
and a few other things that we have got
going on in our life we actually have
regular great cash flow you have the
same that has made me feel better is
like getting checks every month and like
seeing the balance go up on a consistent
basis the cash flow like there's a
difference between entrepreneurs I found
between who sell and just make windfalls
versus who have a business that they
fully own and they're able to take out
income every quarter or every year um
and having that cash flow definitely
makes me feel better oh no doubt you
always want to be making money and also
it keeps you in shape being subject to
trying to make as much money as spend or
ideally more at any age keeps you in the
market you have to you have to
understand what the market values and
doesn't value it keeps you it's how I I
think it keeps me that an exercise keeps
me is is hopefully going to keep me sort
of young and that
is understanding how how to how to
create something in the marketplace
whether it's a podcast or a book or a
talk for me that people are willing to
pay for Keeps Me In the game it keeps
keeps me in the ring it keeps me in
shape uh so I think it's really
important to and also you're right it
does if you let the end of the year no
okay if my even if my investments are
down 20 or 30% which they were last year
I'm still making you know almost as much
or more than I spend that's that you do
get huge comfort and peace from that you
know one of the things we like to do on
this podcast is um that's different than
most is that we we ask every guest who
comes on about what they're seeing now
so like so far we talked about the past
and most podcasts are just about your
past how you how'd you do it but um we
like to talk about Trends opportunities
B what what business would you be
starting or do you see as something
people could start now right like if you
go on if you go on hot ones you eat hot
wings if you come on MFM you talk about
ideas and opportunities that's sort of
the stick um in fact we almost canceled
this podcast because we didn't know if
you were prepped and ready with that but
Sam said no no no he's going to be he's
good he's good off the cuff you'll be
ready um what opportunities or ideas do
you see today that either you know
you're tempted to do or you say no I'm
out of the game but if I was 25 again
this is what I would be running at this
is what I would be working on um this is
a problem that I think somebody could go
solve what do you see out there today so
first off a lot of it is situational
right someone coming out of someone with
a degree from an elite University who
has the ability whose parents will
support them and doesn't have a high
burn or maybe a partner that works you
know it's just a lot of it situational I
I don't like it I've never like this
hustle culture where people say go offer
to carry Jeff bezos's bags or have
coffee because some if you're a single
mother that's just not an option for you
so some of it's situational so I'll go
through a few situations if I'm a young
man or woman and I haven't had the
opportunity to get credentialed I don't
have a traditional four-year college
degree much less a college degree from
Elite
institution I think there going to be a
lot of businesses whether it's carpet
cleaning or gas stations or uh you know
hanging and selling draperies into small
Furniture companies that are owned by
Boomers they're going to need uh
transition nice small
businesses and these individuals will
need liquidity events and they're just
aging out of the business they don't you
know they're hitting their 60s and 70s
and they don't want to be calling
on car washes to sell in you know their
product or whatever it is and these are
businesses doing between half a million
and 10 million a year that have no
succession strategy because if they made
money their kids don't want to be in
this type of business because their kid
went to Emy and wants to go to work at
Google and I would try and find be
really Scrappy about getting into a
business understanding it trying to find
people who own it and figure out a way
to buy it using that person's Capital
approach somebody and say I want to take
over your business I'm going to buy it
slowly over 5 years and then I'm going
to give you coupons so you can retire um
if I'm a credentialed person if I have a
degree unfortunate enough I would go to
work for a big platform I think we live
in an era of of where antitrust is no
longer in effect so the big companies if
you were to divide the stock market into
desiles the 10 the companies with the
largest market cap over the last 30
years have outperform the bottom nine by
huge Factor so going to work for a big
company is vastly underrated they can
abuse their Monopoly position they will
have that mole removed you will get rich
slowly working at Google or at McKenzie
so if you're
credentialed uh you know we over
romanticize entrepreneurship if you have
the ability to get into the greatest
wealth creating vehicle in history and
that is a US Corporation do it but they
have security at the front saying do you
have a degree from an elite college but
if you do absolutely go to work for a
big multinational conglomerate if you're
an entrepreneur
I think that the and credentialed and
can raise money I would say that the
intersection between
Ai and healthare the most disruptable
business in the world is US Healthcare
three and a half to4 trillion dollar
four out of Fe five people aren't happy
with it it's cost of outpaced inflation
for the last 40 years meaning it's got
the biggest chin in the world and I
think the fists of stone coming for it
are uh is artificial intelligence where
we can take Healthcare from a defensive
based industry to offensive I give my
grocery receipts my workout routine My
Health Care
records my sleep patterns to a company
that figures it all out and then gives
me prescripted goes on offense proactive
lifestyle Grocery and exercise
recommendations and I think there's just
going to be a ton of Niche businesses
and health care that leverage some form
of AI are there any out there that you
like yeah uh I'm an investor in a
company called 98.6 that does text-based
health care it's a private company so we
sell into B2B a big you know Sam's and
Sam's offers for $3 a month to every
employee or we charge them three bucks a
month an ability to text somebody in an
AI says okay it's it's a it's a rash
we're getting a dermatologist on the
line they look at the rash using your
smartphone and say this is fine I'm
sending you a cream and hit and or this
needs a prescription we're hitting the
pharmacy
and by the way that that investment I've
written down by 80% it's been really
hard I've I've lost money so far in that
so I don't want to pretend that this is
all easy but I would say if I were young
and had intellectual capital and
credentialing I would go into something
around Ai and healthc care and then man
well like that shocks me that you said
that say that because when I look at
I've done a few Healthcare things and I
look at like the landscape it seems like
impossible to like it just see there
seems like there's a [__] ton of
Regulation figuring out insurance
companies seems like the hardest thing
there is um and even though everyone is
frustrated about their setup this seems
like a like a very challenging space to
crack into and of course there's there's
huge rewards if you can pull it off but
it seems very very challenging I I just
look at this I look at this category and
how much money is in this
category and um it's going to happen
it's just there's never been a business
there's never been a carcass so tempting
so bloated swimming so slowly as
us-based Healthcare we spend $113,000
per person but we die earlier and we're
obese and we're more depressed the UK
spends six and a half thou how can the
UK in Australia be living longer and
spending half what we in the US spend on
health care that's just the mother of
all
chins there's going to be disruption
there and I'd want to get in the way of
that the other thing I'm really excited
about and I think is the most underhyped
I just did a blog post on this I think
gp1 is bigger than gp4 what's gp1 OIC
woia oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah which I
i' I've tested semi glte a ton it's
amazing um like I think there's like so
many crazy implications on what it could
do like I think I think it could i' I've
been saying this I don't know [__] by
the way other than I tested it and I had
drinking problems in the past I think it
could like help solve alcoholism I think
there's so many crazy things there was
this guy on Twitter uh our buddy from CB
insights was like what did he say did he
say that um uh food companies are going
to lose money cuz people are eating less
and he said airline companies are going
to make more money cuz people weigh less
he's like that's how big of a deal these
drugs are if I was starting a hedge Fone
right now I would have a fund that did
nothing but go short food stocks
McDonald's nobody walks into Arby's and
looks around and thinks this was a good
decision no one ever thinks that and if
if all of a sudden I could get an
ejection or take a pill every week that
help me make better decisions our
instincts have not cut up to the
institutional production of our economy
we drink too much we eat any anytime
we're near Salt Fat or sugar we Gorge
because for 99 again 99% of our species
history we couldn't find these things
when mating the majority of men have had
almost no mating opportunities through
history a small minority of men have had
all the meeting opportunities and then
you're presented with a reasonable fact
simile of sex called porn and there's a
there's a decent segment of men out
there who aren't working aren't getting
out of the house because they're staying
home and watching too much porn and
they're also not engaging in
relationships we drink too much I'm
addicted to other people's affirmation
my kid is on Snap too much this could be
scaffolding I mean the weight loss thing
is arguably the biggest addressable
Market in the world 40% of America is
obese 70% is obese and overweight but
even bigger than that this could be the
scaffolding on our instincts to update
our instincts to where they need to be
with in the industrial production that
has gone exponential in the last 100 150
years with assembly line technology the
microprocessor and say okay Scott you
like THC too much you like alcohol way
too much you're too desperate for other
people's affirmation and what people say
about you on Twitter bums you out way
too much much we're going to
calibrate these glp1 drugs to help you
moderate your Cravings I mean what these
things do is they moderate your cravings
when your Cravings are getting the
incorrect signals from 300,000 years of
instinct on on the Savannah and
everybody I mean they're finding out
they're finding out people on OIC drink
60% less alcohol they're biting their
nails
less so the opportunity to update our
instincts for the entire I mean the
market I I'm just I'm blown away by this
thing I think it could be just enormous
and there isn't anybody that doesn't
have that has instincts that has a
behavioral model that is that is driven
by Instinct that is caught up to our
world I don't care who you are have you
tried it I haven't but as you can tell
I'm ready yeah jeez I feel like you just
injected me digitally just now with it
that was
amazing you know how much it costs a
month about 1,000 bucks a month right
it's between $500 and $1,000 a month
when I was trying it it was 500 a month
out of pocket most insurance companies
and and I think if you have diabetes
they actually only cover it I think for
a limited time but most people using it
now are are just paying $500 to $1,000 a
month and here's the crazy [__] about
this drug you have to increase your
dosage every every week so you start
with a very small amount and every two
weeks or so you have to increase it like
forever well I I don't know forever but
over a course of at least a year you
have to so the like when I first started
taking it I would I would test out just
a little bit and it would make me a
little bit sick to my stomach you know
the the downside of there's a few
downsides one is upset stomach and then
after about 3 weeks I'm like all right I
feel great let's let's increase it and
then now at the end of uh 6 months
you're taking 10 times you basically on
a syringe you got to fill thing up to
100 at first you fill it up to 10 and
over a year you have to increase it and
so you have to pay more and more money
what could go
wrong there's a lot of things that can
go wrong with it I like I i' I've tested
it one downside is I actually don't know
if you develop healthy eating habits you
just eat less and you lose muscle you
lose muscle uh there are definitely
downsides to it it's not a terribly new
drug like uh I think that these types of
things have been around for like 30
years so there's some studies but like
the as it's being prescribed now it's
definitely newish so there are
definitely going to be downsides but
it's super promising another one is uh
metformin which isn't in the same um
which isn't in the same category
entirely but it does similar things
that's super interesting I always think
it's interesting when people like Sam
Alman like these Geniuses who like see
everything take it and he's been like
this is the drug I take I take met
Foreman all the time so that's super
fascinating so I agree I think I think
these this classification of drugs is is
quite interesting I mean I was even
thinking I'm trying to figure out the
second order of effects here and
like does Mna stock go down 80% because
the reality is through the pandemic we
the farri weaponized and politicized
mass and vaccines and decided Well if
you take them it means you're far left
so if you're far right you don't want to
take these things on the far left we
weaponized and politicized obesity we
didn't want to acknowledge that 88% of
mortalities had one
comorbidity uh at least that was obesity
related and we started with this Trope
of oh you're not obese you're finding
your tree truth no you're not you're
finding diabetes there's nothing to
celebrate
here and so we decided we didn't want to
have an open conversation about the fact
that America is obese 40% of a the kids
you're more likely to commit suicide
obesity and children it's terrible
you're much more likely to be depressed
as an adult not go to college you become
more likely to kill yourself I mean so
what happens to misto
if all of a sudden we drastically reduce
if you drastically reduce obesity in
America you drastically reduce the
vulnerability of the population to a
Corona virus so do you need Mna I mean
at at some point the reality is a
25-year-old who's thin yeah you get
vaccinated for a variety of reasons but
it's not at some point it becomes less
obvious whether you need these vaccines
when the society is healthy and not
obese I I mean I'm just kind of Blown
Away Hospital networks entire Hospital
networks could go out of business if
they're really honest the milin
institutes that obesity related costs
are $1.7 trillion a year when you look
at everything from knee Replacements to
cardiac to cancers that are obesity
related we're looking at $1.7 trillion a
year that's 7% of our economy so what
happens when the entire economy gets a
cost cut of
7% so I I'd want to get kind of near
this techn I think this technology is
going to have a bigger impact on the
real economy than AI I think AI we've
kind of hit Peak AI I love it I use it a
lot but it's a little bit overhyped
right now we're definitely kind of I
would say I think about a month ago we
hit Peak AI in terms of from an investor
standpoint I would not want to be buying
into AI companies right now as an
entrepreneur I'd want to be raising
money for an AI company but I anyways
you asked me what I was excited about
trying to find a baby boomer that wants
to sell a small business and do seller
financing uh if you're have
certification you're fortunate enough
for whatever reason you either have Rich
parents or you're freakishly remarkable
and you ended up at Dartmouth go to work
for a big American company we are
they're amazing you'll get rich slowly
smart people great place to meet mentors
great place to meet mates you just just
these companies are totally underrated
in terms of their power and what they
can do for you professionally and
economically
uh if you're an entrepreneur something
around Healthcare and Ai and I think
from an investment standpoint uh I just
want to be near I'm very excited about
glp1 as an emerging technology we need
to get you to start taking it so we can
well have have you not taking it because
you're afraid of the side effects or if
you're not taking it because you're like
I'm already cut I don't need this oh no
I'd like look I think I I don't know
this but who who gop1 should
be uh who who should could reach right
now is poor and middle-income households
that are obese that's where the greatest
societal benefit would be right now who
I think is probably driving the sales
are rich people who want to lose the
last 10 or 20 pounds that's my gut my
gut is that the people taking it right
now the Hollywood drugs 100% dude I went
to I went to CVS the other day I had to
get like the whooping cough vaccine and
I went to CVS and I had to wait for an
hour to get the vaccine five people were
in line I the [__] worst thing about
CVS and Walgreens is they say out loud
oh are you here to pick up your simala
like they say it like really loud like
and I'm like the [__] five people had
lied and it was all older people who
looked like they had diabetes five
people they were like oh are you here
for the OIC and like they say what the
pricing is and they go all right I'll
pay it and and and these people it it
was like the white New Balance crowd it
wasn't like a like you know like it was
a Wrangler jeans crowd this wasn't like
a like a high they didn't I didn't
stereotype these people as like yuppies
and they were swiping their card just
jump up and yell cyia oh wait you said
something else never
mind I hate that about the phes where
they say I'm like can you can you shut
the [__] up Scott this could be your
philanthropy thing you should be giving
away gop1 to the to the masses that
could be your moment that nobody's on
that train so I you inspired a thought
like when I was 19 I I had terrible I
had terrible acne growing up and it was
a real source of enormous insecurity for
me and I was painfully thin I look like
kabad crane with bad skin and it was
just really really
painful and I was starting to get scars
on my face cuz my acne was so bad and I
started taking taking acutane and it was
about the time I made the crew team at
UCLA and I put on a bunch of weight and
a bunch of muscle and my skin cleared up
and it literally changed my life it just
changed my life uh and not only because
uh uh you know I was people were more
attracted to me and I started having sex
which was a wonderful thing in my life
but I just felt so much better about
myself and still to this day and it's
probably inappropriate I was at a gas
station and the gas attendant had just
terrible acne and I'm like take this as
you want I don't mean to offend you but
if you heard you know there's there's
there there's great drugs uh for this so
I'm out there basically trying to
prescribe as not as an unlicensed
doctor um I don't know what made me
think of that but uh this drug that drug
literally I I found the guy who invented
it this guy who sold the patent to
Hoffman L Ro and I tried to write him a
letter and they're like well he's dead
but we appreciate the letter um anyways
anyways but no I haven't taken it I
haven't taken it I do take I do take
creatine uh I struggle with and no one's
going to feel bad about this I struggle
with keeping weight on creatine's all
the now you said uh uh I've made a bunch
of money and I just don't feel good and
uh God it's hard for me to to put weight
on I just keep losing it so you're two
for two on uh
unlikable Cry Me a River boss cry me a
river yeah I'm too rich and too thin oh
yeah Professor punchable we got
Professor punch ha that guy I hate that
guy well you you do get a lot of punches
there's the the what's it called the
inverse um the
inverse index Gallow index what do you
think about that that's pretty good I
like that yeah and the craziest call was
the Macy's the Macy's call that was a I
want to apologize in advance but I'm
going to sound defensive the Macy's call
was I said that multi- channel I said
that about 10 years ago in Germany at a
talk and I said that multi- channel
retail was the future of marketing and
that Macy's who had a great website and
stores I said that was the future and in
the same talk I said I believe Amazon
Will Buy stores and I said I think
Amazon will buy Whole Foods but my
detractors don't take that clip they
take the clip when I said the future
looks more like Macy's the anti- Gallow
ETF or index it's a bit cherry-picked
because I know my picks and they've
actually done pretty well but um the
reality is the G the the index says
since October 4th 2019 tech companies
that the professor has predicted would
fail have outperformed the S&P and seen
a whopping 61% return even excluding
Tesla when was that published I don't
know because I I think I well one I
picked I picked some companies that
would lose that skyrocketed specifically
Tesla um but I think someone who tracks
it as of last year the end of last year
because a lot of those stocks got
hammered it was it was it was up again
but I want to be clear I get I get it
wrong all the time and someone who makes
predictions like me should be held
accountable what I find though is that
the in people stop tracking the
index when it's there's no longer a
story there when I I mean this is what I
found um when I talk about when I say
that I think that Tesla is overvalued by
the way you're right last updated uh on
one of these the inverse Gallow
index.com last updated 228 2022 which
no one's interested because the narrativ
when the market started to turn yeah
because quite frankly the index is
probably overperforming right now and no
one's interested in that because the
people who invented the index what I
find generally especially on Twitter is
when I am disparaging about a company or
cryptocurrency the people who are along
that start engaging in not only
professional ass uh assassination but
character assassination whenever someone
really comes after me I'm like they must
be an investor and one of the companies
I have been critical of I would say
don't never get in between a venture
capitalist and their second million
because they will take to Twitter and
call you a plagiarist or accuse you of
having done terrible things at NYU which
you've never ever been accused of much
less people have people have found you
guilty of what what did they accuse you
of I'm not even going to go there I've
been accused of everything like Behavior
stuff or just getting uh picks wrong oh
I know it gets really ugly and then you
click on the Twitter account it's a
picture of a dog and there's no it's an
anonymous
account I think that there are Venture
capitalists who you know fairly well who
when I'm when I'm saying this company
this cryptocurrency this coin the
underlying technology there is no
underlying technology and they are
funding it with their brand name such
that they can dump it because they don't
have to disclose their sales and they
hire a PR agency that creates 10,000
Bots and then creates a list of people
who don't think Crocket is going to
replace the dollar here I've got a good
shirt that you can where for for when
you're having those conversations for
virgins no I would say yeah no it's for
people yeah that's right it it means you
never kissed a girl
um anyways but what I have found is and
I wasn't used to getting attack like
that and every time I tried to you know
I I hired a firm to unmask some of the
people who were attacking me it was
clearly like the same language I'm like
they're using fake accounts and it was
almost always someone who had a large
financial position in the company that I
said
was overvalued but look at the end of
the day I should be held accountable and
when I get it wrong you know I'll have
several million people on Twitter point
it out um but as somebody who is very
close to his own stock picks you things
have kind of worked out over here wait
wait you hired a firm to figure out
who's behind these Twitter accounts I
think it's so I I think it's political
I've been very critical of
Putin and I'm fairly and I know this
sounds paranoid but it doesn't mean I'm
wrong if I if I were Putin I would hire
I would spend a small amount of money
I'm spending hundred billion dollar a
year in Ukraine and 100,000 Lives why
wouldn't I take 5% of that or5 billion
dollar and take some very bright
scientists and uh do AI generated AB
testing and create a list of my five
seven 10,000 biggest detractors who are
pro Ukraine and start slowly but surely
undermining their Authority on social
media platforms that have AAL aoral
management team who will cash my checks
and slowly but surely start undermining
their Authority that's what I would do
do you have any proof that anything like
that has happened or is this just going
to my comments go go any I don't know
you that's that in itself is not pro it
could just be someone time anytime you
say any you'll do it go on and talk
about Ukraine and you're going to start
to see a lot of people attacking you
personally and professionally who are
anonymous and you could say wow it's
just amazing that all of these Anonymous
Bots seem to have decided to engage in
character
assassination because I consistently Am
pro Ukraine and wouldn't they be stupid
not to do it because people don't look
click on the profile they just see the
comment and it's always the same
language Professor Galloway I don't know
it's like what what's the threshold of
your I in my eyes you're a big deal but
what the threshold of you're a big deal
to decision makers who decide these
things but it's all about public opinion
you can't win a war without public
support you can't lose one with public
support so the Putin the fastest Blue
Line path to victory in Ukraine for
Putin is the election of Donald Trump in
my view and also uh trying to diminish
or reduce public support for the war
there so wouldn't they be stupid to not
have the gru identify the 10,000 most
critical PE or biggest supporters of UK
Ukraine and slowly but surely undermine
their credibility that's what I why
would they'd be stupid not to do that
especially on platforms that will cash
anybody's checks and as it relates to
the fog of misinformation are [__]
smoke
machines why on Earth would they not do
that no I mean I I think they should I I
was just I'm giving you a hard time of
like are you are you a big enough fish
which that that's what that's what I'm
trying to figure out oh I might be
20,000 out of a list of 20,000 people
but I think I've made the list when
it's actually the like Forbes 30 under
30 [__] Putin's 10,000 under 10,000
that's the list that's the real list of
influence right there if you go on Face
the Nation and say this is the best
investment in the history of the West
unifying for the first time Europe is a
union we've taken NATO out of the brain
coma we pushed back on a murderous
fascist 90 years ago this is a wonderful
moment for the West it's 10% of our
military but this is the best investment
we ever made I think that qualifies me
to get on the list
that's what um well are are you enjoying
being Scott Galloway the brand more than
being Scott Galloway the founder of like
an are you enjoying it more than being
an operator of companies or are you
enjoying uh I mean you have some cool
blog posts where you're like when people
say hi to me in the streets I love it it
makes me feel great which one are you
enjoying more Scott Galloway the brand
or Scott Galloway the business person oh
on the whole this is really wonderful I
mean people come up to me
and are super nice and you know I'm at
that I have 13 and 16y old boys so
everything I do is just like tragically
uncool in their eyes they don't really
seem to like me a great deal so when
someone comes up to me it happened
yesterday and like wants a picture with
me and they're excited to meet me in
front of my boys to be honest it just
feels really nice and people generally
speaking are just so nice and they come
up and I get to meet new people yeah
it's awesome and it feels very
gratifying I'm also we talked about a
addictions I'm addicted to affirmation
from strangers it's sort of pathetic but
I at least know it so I can modulate it
and it's really wonderful people are
really friendly and really nice you know
I went to the Arsenal game with my boys
and a bunch of people came up to me and
said hi and I was at the Taylor Swift
conference uh concert and the
16-year-old girl had made me a bracelet
and came up and gave me a bra I mean
it's just like I have all these
wonderful moments with strangers so it's
wonderful I do think there is an
algorith for happiness though a pretty
good one and that is to be rich but
Anonymous cuz at some point I'm going to
become the villain and some of the
things you talked about before there's
an entire industry in America around
building people up and then tearing them
down and so I wonder when my story turns
to the villain because you know at some
point I'll probably [__] up and say
something really stupid and then Wham
people will weigh in but for the time
being oh it's wonderful people are nice
I just it's so rewarding really
rewarding
we're um we're coming up on the on our
time but I I had one one last question I
saw you talk uh I've seen you talk a few
times and I've watched your stuff on
YouTube the difference between your
talks and most everyone's talks is you
kind of break a bunch of the rules so
you have like 150 slides uh each slide
has lots of information on it and you
talk super fast you've got a really
beautiful Rhythm that it's I say fast
but fast in a good way what is the
process of like coming up with one these
talks because your talks seem way more
lucrative like one of your talks would
be like maybe a big blog post that I
wrote or that I would write and I
imagine having like a talk is
significantly more lucrative and
probably way more fun you could travel
all all over the world and and deliver
them what's uh what's that process of
like do you start with a headline and
you're like let me go find data you find
a data point and you're like I'm going
to build something around this yeah so
speaking is the most lucrative business
I've ever been and I had 340 inbound
requests for speaking speaking I
accepted 30 of them I average $112,000
per speaking
engagement and my attitude is someone's
going to pay me
$112,000 I can't just show up and be
charming and interesting and like be me
on stage I've got to bring something
really unique and so I will spend the
better part of three months with a team
of analysts at prop G trying to come up
with themes and data and slides and
humor and video clips
and then choreograph it and practice it
over and over and then test it and try
and make it something where you go okay
when I mean just like a comedian well
humor is a great way to lower people's
defenses such that they'll be open to
new ideas and so when I say things that
are provocative or I'm asking them to
think something different humor is a
fantastic way to soften the beach for
new ideas but you're testing your like
you know before you get the Netflix show
you're like testing it on the on the on
the small um yeah but if I'm a if I'm a
MasterCard and they're spending me 100
you know they're spending 150,000 bucks
to have me speak for an hour in
Barcelona which I did last week you
can't just show up and be Scott Galloway
I've got to be a guy who rep who gets
finds these incredibly smart people to
pull data together and that do a great
job in my design team and you know
greatness is in the agency of others so
but it's a ton of fun I get to go to
interesting places I get to pick the
most
interesting cool ones and it's a nice
and I have an impact I talk a lot about
struggling young men which is really
something I'm passionate about and is
really rewarding I feel like I'm having
a difference I get to go to cool places
so I kind of feel like it's my Victory
lap right now I get to just sort of run
around and you know but I'm but if
someone's going to pay that kind of
money you just can't show up and just
start talking and you know a bunch of
War stories about how awesome you are
you got to show up with real insight or
something that's going to catalyze a
conversation with data they haven't seen
before back to the drawing board for me
then I thought that's uh I thought what
I was doing is uh showing up and giving
myself a Victory lap dude have you seen
one of his talks like every slide has
like a data point that is quite good and
a story behind it and I'm like dude just
finding this data is is a job you're
you're an excellent performer uhal
speaker and like Sam said you're very
lyrical we we enjoy uh we enjoy what you
do I think you're you're really great at
what you do I don't know how you were as
an entrepreneur but like I I feel like
this is what you were meant to do is to
uh to be smart and then um you know
package that up and perform that because
you can't educate without entertaining
and you do a great job of both um thanks
for coming on we really appreciate it
thank you guys congrats on your success
yeah thank you we I think you and I I I
think our pods are are uh going back and
forth sometimes in the chart so I look
forward to uh uh kick in your ass I will
bury
you see you trenches uh thanks man we
appreciate it Scott Galloway thanks
again guys that's the
[Music]
pod